[موسيقى
] في السبعينيات من القرن الماضي ، كانت الخطوط الجوية
آشلي منظمة من قبل قسم
النقل ، وبالتالي فإن الطريقة الوحيدة التي
يمكن لشركة طيران أن تنافس بها في الواقع من حيث الحكمة
لديها علامة تجارية رائعة خارج
بان آم ، وقد بذلت جهودًا كبيرة
لتحفيز كل فرد من حواسك
عندما تمشي على الأقدام.  على متن الطائرة ، هذه
تجربة Pan Am حيث نقدم
نفس القائمة تمامًا مع الخدمة في
السبعينيات من القرن الماضي ، كل شخص يرتدي ملابس ريترو
ويتوقع الجميع حقًا أن يكون
في آلة زمنية تقف الآن على
السطح العلوي لطائرة Pan Am 747 في هذه المنطقة  كان في
الواقع للاستخدام الحصري
لركاب الدرجة الأولى أسفل السلالم ، لقد أصبحت
[الموسيقى]
مهووسة حقًا بـ Pan Am في
سن مبكرة حقًا عندما كنت أتجول ،
ذهبت في أول رحلة لي من Pan Am 747 إلى
أوروبا وفي اللحظة التي مشيت فيها  على متن
تلك الطائرة ورأيت هذا
الدرج الملتوي الذي كنت مدمنًا عليه إلى الأبد
[موسيقى]
بدأت في جمع الأشياء الصغيرة في
ذلك الوقت مثل الجداول الزمنية
وبطاقات الأمتعة ونماذج الطائرات ، لكن
مع تقدمي في السن  أصبحت
الأشياء والأشياء التي أريدها في الواقع
أكبر بشكل كبير من وظيفة إلى أخرى ، لقد
صادفتها لكابتن
مالك هوليوود ، لقد بدأنا بالفعل في
العمل معًا وبشكل جماعي
تصورنا فكرة تجربة Panem هذه ، وقد أظهرها لنا
الكثير من الناس
أن لديهم  بطاقة الصعود إلى
الطائرة على الهاتف نقول لهم ما هي
تلك السنة في 1970 التي أتت الآن
من بالم سبرينغز ، لقد طرت بالفعل
هذا الصباح على متن ناقلة أخرى.
كل دمعة
[موسيقى]